Heute im Rasenfunk.
Keiner wird mich für das machen. Ich kann hier sitzen und genießen. Ich kann auf mehreren Teams gehen, weil ich andere Spieler mag. Ich glaube, das ist eine Möglichkeit, die Ähnlichkeit zu machen.
Hallo, hallo, willkommen zu Rasenfunk, die internationale Edition. Wenn du ein englischer Hörer bist, steig mit mir an, es gibt ein paar deutsche Wörter, aber das ist ein internationaler Episode. Es ist meistens in Englisch. Du kannst den nächsten Teil skippen, wenn du willst. Und das mache ich genau jetzt. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Rasenfunk. Na, das war mein überraschender Einstieg. Auch für mich immer mal wieder was Neues machen. Warum habe ich gerade auf Englisch gesprochen? Nun ja, weil diese Folge hier, wir haben sie ja auch schon angekündigt, hauptsächlich auf Englisch stattgefunden hat. Annika hat für uns ein richtig tolles Interview geführt mit Dr. Kasey Symons. Wenn ihr Name euch noch kein Begriff ist, dann werdet ihr nach diesem Tribünengespräch schlauer sein. Annika hat vor Ort in Australien ein Interview mit ihr geführt. Dieses Interview ist auf Englisch, aber wie wir euch versprochen haben, haben wir auch für eine Möglichkeit gesorgt, für alle diejenigen, die des Englischen nicht mächtig sind oder nicht so gut mächtig sind oder vielleicht auch einfach begleitend auf Deutsch mitlesen wollen. Wenn ihr in die Show Notes geht, dann findet ihr dort ein PDF mit einer erst automatisch erstellten und dann noch mal von uns überprüften Übersetzung dieses Gesprächs. Ich habe dort auch die einzelnen Kapitelmarken als Zwischenüberschriften eingefügt. Das heißt, solltet ihr sagen, Mensch, ich verstehe das leider nicht, aber mich interessiert das Thema, dann bekommt ihr diese Folge zum Lesen. Und ich hoffe, das ist dann für euch auch akzeptabel. In diesem Sinne, schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt. Herzlichen Dank an alle, die uns unterstützen. Auch ihr habt diese Folge möglich gemacht. Darunter sind unter anderem Bene, Meta, Baron, Ulli, the Hero, na das passt ja, Wilmes, CL3 und Mach de Bourgier. Ach ja, Mach de Bourgier, würde ich sagen. So ist es richtig. So, herzlichen Dank für eure Unterstützung. Der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Wir sind light, rein crowd-gefundet. Herzlichen Dank an alle, die uns unterstützen. Auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclubfindet ihr alle Informationen. Und ich will jetzt gar nicht zu viel Vorrede machen. Es folgt jetzt wirklich ein interessantes Gespräch. Ich denke, ihr habt es an den O-Tönen im Intro schon gemerkt. Es wird hier mal ganz anders über Frauensport gesprochen und über Weiblichkeit im Fandasein. Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß mit dem Interview. Ab jetzt übernimmt Annika. Annika wird das Ganze auf Englisch schwören. Annika schmeißt uns auch aus der Sendung raus. Und dann freuen sowohl Annika als auch ich mich sehr auf euer Feedback unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de oder in den sozialen Netzwerken. Ich würde sagen, das reicht. Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß mit dem Interview. Let's go!
Du bist ein Postdoctoral-Research-Frau an der Swinburne-Universität hier in Melbourne. Und du recherchierst Fans und Fandomen, und insbesondere Frauenfans und Gender-Bias, die wir in einiges von euch sehen werden. Und letztendlich, aber definitiv nicht zuletzt, bist du sehr beschäftigt und eine sehr erfreulichere Person hier in Australien während der Weltcup. Also, hallo und willkommen zu Rasenfunk.
Vielen Dank, dass du mich hier haben hast, Annika, für diese wundervolle und liebende Erinnerung. Aber es sind alles tolle Dinge, die ich hier haben kann. Und wir sind eine sehr sportfokussierte Community, also gibt es viele Möglichkeiten. So wie ich es mache, fühle ich mich, dass ich viele Dinge machen kann, die ich liebe. Ich bin Fan, wie du gesagt hast, wenn ich mich mit Leuten vorstelle, finde ich es sehr schwer, meinen Jobtitel in etwas zu bezeichnen, das einfach zu sagen ist.
Und durch Früfe, die Leute, die zu diesem Thema hören, wissen, haben wir uns in einer Bundesliga-Match mit meinem Frauen-Side-Club gespielt, das ist SGS Essen gegen Torbina Potsdam. Und du hast eine sehr fabulöse Schale gekauft.
Ich habe es über meinen Tisch, also wenn die Leute rein kommen, sehen sie die rote und die weiße. Und sie fragen, was das Team ist. Das ist so seltsam. Wie haben sie uns gefunden? Das hat uns so gemacht, dass das genau das ist, warum es so interessant und mit so vielen Möglichkeiten mit der Sport-Fans-Fan-Gruppe geht. So viele Fans aus dem ganzen Welt haben diese tollen Plattformen und die sozialen Medien in einer Art, die sie noch nicht haben. Als ich in Deutschland kam, habe ich Mara und einige der anderen tollen Frauen als Teil des Teams in Mainz getroffen. Ich hatte eine tolle Nacht mit ihnen und habe etwas mit Mara gesagt. Ich möchte wirklich ein Bundesliga-Match sehen, aber mein Reise-Schedule lässt mir nicht viel. Sie hat mir die Karte für mich angeschaut und gesagt, du wirst in Cologne sein, wenn Essen spielt, das ist wirklich nah. Das wird toll sein. Und wir können sehen, was man mit den Plattformen, die wir alle auf der Welt und in anderen Sport-Kodiengängen machen. Und es gibt viele andere Kollektiven, die auf den Sport-Koden konzentriert sind. Und wenn wir an tolle Events wie der WM-Weltcup treffen, wie die letzten paar Wochen, sich wieder zu sehen und andere Frauen, die ich auf Social Media kenne, in der realen Leben. Das ist das Coole an dem Moment, was in der Frauensport-Zeit passiert ist.
Es ist einfach toll, die letzten paar Wochen hier zu sein. Wie haben diese verschiedenen Positionen, die du in der Vergangenheit behältest, und jetzt in der Akademie, deine Sicht auf Sport und Fan-Dom aufgetragen?
Aber der größte Beziehung, den ich je gespielt habe, war, als Fan zu sein. Ich liebe unsere localen Aussie-Ruhrs-Fußball-Matches in meiner Community und meine Freunde und Familie zu sehen. Aber in dem Moment war immer noch etwas missbraucht, was ich in meinem Rollen genießen wollte. Ich war nicht wirklich sicher, was das war, aber die Möglichkeiten kamen an, für mich weiter zu studieren. Ich war so in Liebe mit diesem Sport und meinem Team, und ich war in diesem Umfeld gearbeitet, dass ich es einfach perfekt fand. Ich habe wirklich keine Literatur gesehen auf diese komplizierten Erfahrungen, die Frauen und non-binary Menschen haben, als Fans von eliten Männern im Sport. Manchmal ist es eine toxische Maske, eine männliche Hegemone. Das hat mich nicht gut gefühlt, aber ich habe das immer mehr begonnen und ich habe gemerkt, dass ich meinen Sport, meinen Team, und ich werde nie von ihnen weggehen, weil ich diese Passion als Fan habe. Aber dann fing es an, mehr breit zu schauen. Ich fühlte mich empfohlen in der Frauenfußball-Szene. Ich muss nicht 100% alle Fakten und die Spieler-Namen kennen. Es wird keiner von mir Spaß machen, das zu tun. Ich kann auf mehreren Teams gehen, weil ich verschiedene Spieler mag. Dann bin ich damit ein bisschen mehr sicher, dass ich die Fan-Identität, die ich nicht liebe, und jetzt bin ich ein bisschen mehr bereit, die Dinge zu ändern, die ich will, und wie ich als Fan sein will.
Und ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe mein erstes Sport, die Australian Rules Football, in der AFLW, die neue Frauenfrau-League, die 2017 eröffnet wurde, angefangen. Es brachte viele Menschen in. Es gab Fans, die sagten, dass es Athleten auf ihrem Team waren, die verletzt wurden von Sexuallessort und Domestik. Das ist der Peak des Sportentretäments. Wir machen das ein bisschen. Ich habe ein paar Dinge gesehen, wie die Weltcup. St. Pauli ist interessant. Es ist egal, dass wir nicht physisch da sind. Das ist eine sehr coole Sache. Es ist definitiv ein erhebendes Feld. Es gibt einige unglaubliche Leader in diesem Feld, die in diesem Bereich arbeiten. Von einer Frau, die nur in Männern und Sport versucht, und dann zu verstehen, dass das nicht der einzige Raum, der möglich ist, und diese unglaublichen anderen Späße zu finden, die diese trauerhaften Frauen für eine lange Zeit gebaut haben. Die Golf-Fan-Kultur ist wirklich cool. Also hoffentlich ist das ein bisschen ein Hinweis.
Ich glaube, Fans oder Fan-Dom sind eigentlich beobachtet, wenn es Männer-Sport ist. Oder wie in Deutschland ist es viel Männer-Fussball, weil das der Nummer 1 Sport in Deutschland ist. Aber auf der anderen Seite glaube ich, dass Fans des Frauenfußball sehr unbeobachtet sind, zumindest in Deutschland, und manchmal fühlen sie sich unbeobachtet oder nicht so viel.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist die Millionen Dollar-Fanfrage. Und das ist etwas, das ich in meiner Forschung ein wenig ausweichen will, ist, dass es so etwas nicht gibt. Das wird sehr einzigartig. Die Forschung, die ich mache, mit verschiedenen Fans zu reden, ist ein Konzept, das in Frauenfußball nicht existiert. Aber ich denke, das größte Unterschied, das ich in Frauen- und Männerfußball sehe, ist, dass viele Männer und Fans von Männerfußball nur ein Fan sind. Wenn das Team sie enttäuscht, werden sie wütend und warten auf das nächste Spiel. Ich will das nicht verweigern, denn deine Fan-Benehmigung ist sehr wichtig für dich. Ich denke, das ist der größte Unterschied zwischen den beiden. Ich weiß noch nicht die Antwort zu dieser Frage, aber ich denke, das ist ein wirklich interessanter Punkt der Unterschied.
Aber ich denke, ein halbes Jahr vor, wurde eine Entscheidung gemacht, dass jedes Finale für die nächsten paar Jahre in Sydney gespielt wird. Ich meine, es war so groß, dass es mich sogar erhielt.
Und nicht nur die A-League, auch die Netball-Australien schauen sich auch an diese Verhältnisse. Das Verkauf der Finals in Sport ist hier ein bisschen passiert. Das ist die Liste, die einige Sport-Kodes hier nehmen. Weil es nicht so ist, wie wir es hier machen, gibt es viel Resistenz. Authentizität in Sport ist etwas, das wir sehr ernst nehmen. Ob es eine Fan-Kollegung ist, wenn sie ein authentisches Fan sind oder nicht, was du entscheidst, authentisch ist. Wir sind in Australien verbunden mit den Strukturen der Sport-Clubs, wo die Fans Mitglied sind. Auch die Dinge, die ich vorhin schon erwähnt habe, aus einer Gender-Perspektive, die man als Fan beantworten kann. Man will nicht für ihre Behinderung befürworten.
Ich weiß definitiv die konflikten Gefühle. Ich bin ein Schalke-Supporter, die eine sehr lange Zeit mit Gasprom hatten, eine russische Gas-Kompanie. Aber was ich interessant fand, über die Diskussionen, über die Proteste oder die verschiedenen Weisen der Proteste, ist, dass du natürlich auch Proteste im Stadion hast, die voll sind, die verbrannt sind, wo du Banner oder spezielle Chancen gegen oder für etwas hast. Aber ich denke, in Frauenfußball kann es ein bisschen anders sein, weil die Numeren der Fans in den Stadions aufwachsen. Er sah es in Essen, da ist nur ein Stand leer, aber auf der TV, egal wie viele Leute da sind, sieht man immer die anderen, die leer sind, weil das der Seite, an dem die TV-Kameras sind.
Ja, sicher. Ich glaube, es gibt so viele Dinge, die im Moment im Sport an WM protestieren. Das Momentum ist wirklich positiv, und es gibt noch so viele gute Dinge, die noch zu verändern sind. Ich sehe das, warum die meisten Fans auf Social Media zu protestieren. Es ist fast wie ein Aktivprotest, wenn man sich aufsteht. Ich denke, dass Fans des WM Sport viel Arbeit machen. Du kaufst dir ein WM-Ticket, du kaufst ein WM-Ticket, du wirst von denen was erwarten. Ich denke, das macht das Konzept der Protesten sehr anders und viel komplizierter.
Wir haben keine Goalkeeper-Jungs. Aber auf der anderen Seite gibt es die Matildas, wo Nike sagt, wir haben vor der Weltcup schon so viele T-Shirts verkauft, definitiv mehr als die Soccer-Roulette, die wir im World Cup und danach verkaufen.
Ich denke, das ist eine interessante Position, insbesondere in dieser Zeit, in der wir so viel Fokus auf Sustainabilität, Klima und Fast Fashion haben. Sie sind also bereit, dafür zu warten. Sie haben jetzt die größte inklusive Range eines Jerseys und es ist die Männer auszuholen. Sie machen das in diesen kleinen Zeiten, die sich auf Social Media kreieren, und die Karten von. Ich finde das sehr staggierig, wenn das ein Risikfaktor ist. Aber sie haben nichts anderes. Und sie hatten auch Training-Shorts. Nicht Matchday-Shorts, aber Training-Shorts. Und ich fragte, welchen Fan einen Training-Shorts kaufen wird, um an einem Stadion zu stehen und zu schauen. Die Kinder können das nicht tragen. Willen sie einfach einen Hoodie, der sagt, zum Beispiel, dass es die Matilda-Tourne gibt, diese Sachen sind definitiv für die Matilda-Tourne, aber für andere Teams. Also hoffentlich gibt es auch andere Sport-League und Teams, die das Markt für diese Sachen haben. Und deine Fans wollen was, weil sie es selbst machen werden, und das sehen wir auch. Ich habe definitiv viele Matilda-Geräte gekauft, diese Women's World Cup, habe viel Geld auf sie verwendet, was ich glücklich mache, aber auch viele Dinge, die Fans machen, weil sie immer noch Dinge machen, die ich denke, die andere Seite ist, die die Fans-Kulturen an Frauenfußball verändern, und ich finde, dass es Dinge gibt, die ich sehr gerne sehe, die in Konflikt mit der Fan-Identität sind, wie wenn es ein Mannsport ist, wo zwei Team-Logos auf etwas sind, oder ein Spieler, der noch ein Klub spielt, aber ich liebe diesen Spieler, und das ist so viel mehr in der Sport-Komunikation in den Frauen. Ich denke, dass es definitiv Platz für beide gibt. Aber hoffentlich ist die Lesung von der World Cup so, dass wenn du es machst und du verstehst, was deine Fans wollen, kannst du eine Weise finden, die sich entzündet und profitabel ist.
Wie ist das WM in der Weltcup, wie ist es durch die größere Medienkollege, Fußball und besonders die Matildas in Australien, hier hergekommen?
Ich war alleine und ich hatte im Mittwoch keine Chance, in die Ausländer zu gehen, also ich konnte keine Auffälligen aus Australien finden, aber die Spiele, die ich dort war, ich war alleine, ich sah nicht wirklich viele große Fangruppen oder viele Dinge, die im Stadion händen. Ich habe nicht weggekommen und gedacht, hier ist die große Fan-Kultur, hier sind einige supporterische Gruppen. Das war echt cool, einfach zu sehen. Ich dachte, okay, jeder ist hier, jeder ist hier für den Weltcup. Ja, ein bisschen Bente, wir lieben die Bente. Vielleicht, wenn ich mit Fußball um ein längeres Zeitpunkt gewachsen wäre, wie gesagt, ich bin ein ziemlich neuer Fan, es sind nur die letzten fünf Jahre, dass ich mit Frauenfußball begonnen habe. In den meisten Männer's World Cup-Mensmatchen in Australien kaufe ich nur ein einziges Ticket. Ich fahre mit Leuten vor dem Spiel, sehe Freunde und Bekannte oder Menschen aus der Social Media, die ich in der Stadion in Person treffen kann. Man setzt sich auf die Namen auf. Das war für mich meine Erfahrung mit der Fan-Kultur und das hat mich in diesem Women's World Cup eine wunderbare Erfahrung gemacht.
Ich bin ein bisschen traurig, weil ich hier als Journalist sehr privilegiert bin, immer auf dem Presstribuium sitzen. Aber so viele Male komme ich zu einem Stadion, bevor jeder andere da ist, oder die ersten Leute kommen, und dann sitze ich da, kann nicht mit den Fans verbinden, und dann muss ich sehr lange nach dem letzten Schuss bleiben, und wieder kann ich nicht mit den Fans verbinden, und jeder andere hat, ich weiß nicht, gewandert. und Kanada-Fans einfach aufgeteilt war, und sie singten Szenen, die sich für die anderen äußern, aber in einem sehr humorös, witzig, Spaß, Art, und Weise.
Es ist hart, als Journalist zu sein. Das ist sehr gut und wir sind auch bereit. Das ist nicht mein Skillset. Ich werde nur meine kleinen Fans bleiben.
Du siehst auch Fans und Fan- Die Fans sind meistens, ich meine, sogar auf einem Show wie Ted Lasso, wo du diese Frauen im Fußball arbeitest, verschiedene Bildungen von ihnen. Und dann ist diese Frau, die den Bar arbeitet, wo alle Fans hängen. Und sie ist natürlich eine sehr starke Person und ein Experte in ihrem Klub.
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Du bist richtig, ich denke, wir werden mehr und mehr Diversität in unserem Sport erzählen, nicht so viel, wie ich sehen möchte, aber wir bekommen, weil das Trend der Streaming-Services und Investitionen in independent und alternative Medien gibt, diese Programme, die versuchen, ein Licht auf mehr diverse Sport zu schenken, Ted Lasso ist ein interessantes Beispiel dafür, aber auch in dem Moment, hast du recht, die Fans sind noch sehr aus diesen Erinnerungen, wir versuchen, mehr Diversität in den Athleten und der Regierung zu zeigen, die Führung von Klubs, die Kochen, was es bedeutet, ein Mann zu sein, eine Frau zu sein, was es bedeutet, in Sport-Späten zu sein.
Wenn du mehr in die Geschichte dicken möchtest, haben wir Links zu Kaseys Arbeit und ihr Social in unseren Shownoten. Auf Twitter kannst du sie finden, via KaseySymons, und auf Instagram, via KaseyRights. Wenn ihr ein englischer Sprecher seid, dann muss ich sagen, dass alle anderen Episoden von Rasenfunk in Deutsch sind. Das ist ein einzigartiges Podcast, finanziert von Community-Donations, das mir auch möglich war, hier bei der Weltcup zu sein und das Tor von Onside zu sehen. Danke euch alle für das. Mein Name ist Annika Becker und das war Rasenfunk aus Australien mit Dr. Kasey Symons.
Das war der Rasenfunk. Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.
Rasenfunk unterstützen ihr Knausa.